I Dean engine remembers the generals
behind turkeys 1980 coup it was the
third coup he'd experienced and it
forced the istanbul-based journalists to
flee to Germany but this time he says
things were different you're modest but
then the military wanted to enforce
their kemalist ideology this time it
appears that everyone's opponents joined
forces with army officers who themselves
want to top military posts Barbados for
the one disco attempt is an opportunity
to speed up the process towards absolute
rule by introducing a presidential
system and exclusivity the Aqua why we
will reject us three victims of the
violence are laid to rest the man threw
themselves in front of tanks in Istanbul
paying with their lives for president
rezept i paired the one and his
supporters their martyrs goes out that
always little they have tanks and guns
but we have the faithful
the answer from the mourners god is
great since the attempted coup everyone
appears to have most of the population
behind him we feed back the traitors now
they must be tried and justly punished
we must keep on marching against them
the people have learned their lesson
this will never happen again hi my
name's shaking the modem machine they
said with sudden lineage what I'm nice
look at if we hadn't taken to the
streets the others would have won but
Allah didn't allow that to happen
turkey mourns the more than 260 victims
of the failed coup attempt and the
country is still in shock but what will
happen next the demonstrations of the
last days were dominated by supporters
of the government although standing up
against the coup plotters the Turkish
opposition fears to become the real
target of the harsh countermeasures
president and Iran vote to take after
the failed coup attempt despite the wave
of arrests across the country life in
Istanbul seems to go on as normal but
many Turks are flying the national flag
on their cars a symbol their remaining
vigilant